hi I'm alive uh if you're looking on
Twitter or Instagram you might have
noticed oh Markiplier died again isn't
that a shame man this picture actually
is scary
um so if you look deeply into my eyes
you might notice that they're a little
bit red I want to point out this this
picture was not photoshopped in any way
straight out of my phone
um is is actually turf
it goes like actually terrifying and I
don't know why but I'm better already
there was a lot of speculation as to why
I was in the hospital and a lot of
speculation as to why my eyes were red
or my beard was half shaven or I had a
bloody lip or I seem to be breaking out
in hives or whatever this was in my hair
there was a lot of speculation okay
so
I'm fine turns out a lot can happen when
you're going for the record for most
blood in a horror movie and so yeah I I
was in the
but not for what people thought
um it wasn't pink eye I didn't get eye
surgery I got eye surgery last year
um and so my vision is much better but
turns out
um sometimes if you go too deep into the
blood uh this will happen and you gotta
go to the doctor to make sure your eyes
aren't melting out of your face
um so that's what I did and I'm fine but
other than that yes it's my birthday go
me go still chugging along not dead yet
um and then
I know that there were uh there were
some people who were very kind and
understanding and
there's some good birthday stuff that
was immediately overshadowed like it was
like birthday celebration as usual and
then like boom Hospital which I think
was one of these memes
and then yeah the the um Davidson's
Markiplier has been in the hospital
account was it was a bad day for them it
was a bad day for them because they uh
they
um they were ready and they already
posted
uh so I'm fine
I've dealt with this three times this
week already
there's a difference between like going
to uh an urgent care and going to the
hospital this is just what happens if
you if you get a boo-boo that's a bit
too bad but turns out you get you get
skipped from right to the front of the
line if you got eye troubles that that's
apparently in the triage order is way up
high so I I got in there quick which I
understand because if I'm about to go
blind I wanna I wanna get some help
pretty fast uh but
they were very nice yeah a lot of a lot
of the Grimace Shake meme you know
you know when I actually die it's gonna
be hilarious like there's gonna be memes
for days uh this could be just like
non-stop barrage like and it's fine I'm
fine with that that is okay I hope I die
in a sufficiently hilarious way that
people can milk that for content and joy
for weeks to come I'm hoping that my
death can be a celebration of memes one
can only hope but I'm fine and it's my
birthday and uh the good news is that
very soon you can expect a new trailer
for iron lung
um and that'll be fun usually when I
have a birthday usually uh usually I'm
not working on it which I was filming on
my birthday but
um usually I ask a little favor for
something uh but this year you know
things have been
pretty good I think it's been going
pretty good so I'm not gonna ask
anything for you guys I've already asked
for a ton I mean I'm already late to my
my birthday so I guess it's over anyway
but thank you guys so much for watching
yeah go put some good out there and
bit more memes or I don't know drink
more Christmas milkshakes it's your day
too so I officially declare it it's your
day it's maybe my birthday but it ain't
only my day and let's let's say that for
guys it's my mom I just spoke with my
son and it's from making shorts for a
new movie it has like I love my mom
because she called me up immediately and
I was already out of the clinic by the
time she called me because that's how
quick it was it was just like are your
eyes exploding no all right get out of
here and then my mom calls me oh you are
dead I'm like no Mom I'm not dead I just
got some blood in the eyes
[Music]
I think yeah go have some fun uh for my
sake I've got plenty of work to do I've
got a lot of editing to do and I've got
a lot of videos to record so I'm gonna
keep up with that and I'll try to uh not
get in the hospital in the any near time
Feud Wolf Man
oh anyway thank you I'm gonna go put
some more eye drops in my eyes because I
need them
thank you for watching
I'll try not to be in the hospital again
bye